bonjour mathieu bolle reddat merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation sur
arte france le medef est reçu en ce
moment même par jean castex je cite il
faudra trouver le moyen de travailler
plus longtemps a dit ce matin geoffroy
roux de bézieux qu'est ce que vous lui
répondez
oui là alors donc on nous ressort cette
marotte macro nist aidé de tous les
ultra libéraux depuis 20 ans de casse de
notre système de retraite de liu faire
travailler plus encore plus longtemps
réformes qu'on avait repoussé un jeu le
rappel par la grève
que le premier ministre est que le
gouvernement veut le remettre sur la
table et donc personne ne va aujourd'hui
évidemment d'ailleurs on j'ai écouté
hier avec gourmandise
aujourd'hui les déclarations de philippe
martinez qui qui sont complètement qui
tombe fort à propos sur les questions
d'urgence sociale aujourd'hui alors que
alors que les les le cac40 pas des
records mais j'ai écouté hier avec
gourmandise ce que disait laurent berger
le secrétaire général de la cfdt qui
était le seul à lime rock
si on est bien vous en rappelez du
gouvernement sur la question de sa
réforme des retraites et qui aujourd'hui
dit qu'elle ne veut pas de réforme des
retraites à quelques mois des
présidentielles pense que tout le monde
a bien conclu aujourd'hui que monsieur
matte on n'est plus le président mais
est le candidat macro qui veut faire feu
de tout bois pour donner des gages au
patronat aux ultralibéraux en montrant
qu'il va mettre les salariés au pas en
nous faisant travailler plus pour gagner
moins et bien évidemment demain comme
hier la cgt sera sur son chemin
justement une large intersyndicale dont
la cgt s'est entendue lundi soir pendant
une journée de mobilisation nationale le
5 octobre avant même de rencontrer un le
gouvernement cette fin de semaine c'est
pas un peu de la provocation est ce
qu'ils vont pas mieux écouter l'autre
avant d'agir un élément qui a évoqué
justement une posture d'écouté pour ces
entretiens de fin de semaine mais hélas
on a bien voulu nous écouter ce que
disait le gouvernement 1 le gouvernement
dès avant la rencontre avec les
confédérations syndicales d avance et
rencontres dit qu'il va remettre sur le
tapis la question de la casse de
l'assurance chômage dès le mois
d'octobre dès début octobre donc il y a
eu lieu huit de se battre le
gouvernement nous dit qu'il va remettre
sur le couvert avant les élections
présidentielles la question de la casse
des retraites et de l'allongement de la
durée la durée de cotisation pour
pouvoir bénéficier d'une pension digne
donc avant même les élections
présidentielles la delà pour cette fin
d'année 2021 donc il y à lui aujourd'hui
que les organisations syndicales
appellent les travailleurs à mettre le
pied dans la porte tr à dire tout de
suite pas touche à l'assurance-chômage
pas touche à la sécurité sociale et à
nos pensions de retraite nous devons
être en vigilance aujourd'hui même en
combat
par rapport à ça mais il ya aussi plein
d'autres sujets qui sont comment faire
face alors face au déficit
la question des salaires et la question
de l'emploi qui sont soit au coeur du 5
octobre évidemment il ya lieu
d'augmenter les salaires de débloquer
les salaires dans une telle crise
aujourd'hui qui fait que les françaises
sont en souffrance aujourd'hui après ce
cette crise sanitaire et et de lutter
contre les plans sociaux et pour la
défense des autres de l'emploi il ya
aujourd'hui plus de mille plans sociaux
qui ont eu lieu depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire on veut faire payer aux
travailleurs la facture économique de la
crise sanitaire et évidemment il faut
que les travailleurs s'empare de ces
questions le 5 octobre dans la grève et
dans la rue ce sera une occasion non
alors du 5 octobre mais il ya aussi le
14 septembre je reviens sur geoffrey
rush de bézieux qui demande un président
du medef qui demandent l'arrêt du pass
sanitaires pour les centres commerciaux
je pense que là en revanche je vous le
rejoignez puisque philippe martinez vos
secrétaire général a dit récemment qu'il
était content l'obligation du pass
sanitaires pour les salariés en contact
avec le public donc la cgt appelle à
manifester le 14 septembre contre
l'obligation
actional et les sanctions qui
s'appliqueront à partir du 15 au
personnel des hôpitaux et des ehpad qui
ne s'y conformeront pas alors ces
organisations de la cgt pas seulement
qu'ils aident toutes les organisations
de la cgt ces fédérations et unions
départementales et sa compagne ont
toutes dit là même où oui à la
vaccination nous ne sommes pas des anti
direct oui à la mecque à la vaccination
mais non à l'obligation non à
l'obligation pour le public qui créerait
des discriminations et non à
l'obligation pour les salariés parce que
c'est pas sanitaire est en passe si bien
ainsi de créer un nouveau six mois un
nouveau motif de sanction
notamment à la sncf puisque vous l'avez
raté syndicaliste à la sncf notamment à
la sncf où
des salariés resteront menacé s'il ne
rompt pas et sont pas en capacité de
présenter un pass impasse vaccinale donc
attendre 5 octobre ce sont les
mobilisations qui vont avoir lieu ça
fait déjà beaucoup de manifestations
trop de manifestations ça tue pas les
manifestations
sans doute pas échappé que tous les
jours il y à des grèves et des
manifestations partout et y compris
pendant l'été notamment contre les
suppressions de postes pour lutter
contre le chômage partiel pour lutter
pour les salaires les emplois dans les
entreprises publiques comme du privé il
ça ne s'est pas arrêtée pendant l'été il
y à des luttes partout dans ce pays
c'est vrai que c'était recouvert dans
l'actualité parce qu'on ne parlait que
du coc vite que des communes et cetera
mais il ya énormément dans ce pays parce
qu'il ya énormément de mécontentement et
effilée partenaires je le dis très très
bien c'est pas aux français aux salariés
devant maintenant qu'il faut s'adresser
c'est aux français aux salariés
d'aujourd'hui et nous avons des
propositions très importantes comme la
question des 32 heures pour le plein
emploi la hausse des salaires des minima
sociaux des embauches est partout et
notamment plus de service public parce
qu'on a bien vu pendant salutaire ce qui
a permis la route c'est le service
public pendant que tous les grands
bourgeois était dans leur maison
secondaire à nous de ray en sologne des
agents du service peut détourner le pays
a assuré le service l'eau face à cette
pandémie merci mathieu bolloré d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes secrétaire général cgt
cheminots à versailles